hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the journey from Neanderthal DNA
to a Nobel Pride how dynabeats magnetic
beads contribute to understanding human
evolution I am Shelley mulak of labroots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Airline dragonhild see it Ireland Rogan
hildesfield has been at Thermo Fisher
for 18 years and in his current role as
r d leader for bead business in Norway
since 2009 for a complete biography of
today's speaker please click their name
in the presentation in the presenters
window at the top right of your screen
of your screen Airlines you may now
begin your presentation
thank you Shelley for the nice
introduction and
welcome good morning good afternoon and
good evening to the audience
so uh as Charlotte said uh so I lead r d
in Thermo Fisher here in Norway and we
are responsible for development of the
magnetic dynabits and with my interest
in fossils paleontology and and
evolution in general I'm really looking
forward to present today's webinar
uh this webinar is of course referring
to and also attribute to swamp de pebo
who is the last year's winner of the
Nobel Prize in physiology or medicine
for his contribution to understanding
human evolution
and in my presentation I want to try to
cover some of his work and key findings
show The Importance Dynamite strep
dividend and next-gen sequencing have
played in advancing this field
and lastly I want to introduce to you
our newly launched dynabeat product that
is optimized for Target enrichment in
the next-gen sequencing workflow
foreign
2022 Nobel Prize winner he's a Swedish
geneticist and professor at both the Max
Planck and The karlinska Institute
he is regarded as one of the founders of
paleogenetics and has worked extensively
on the Neanderthal genome
the journey starts back in 1984 actually
before I should say when he joined his
mother to Egypt got really interested in
mamas but the journey really started in
84 when pebble is a graduate student at
absala but he spends most of his free
time evenings and weekends conducting
strange experiments
he wants basically he wants to extract
DNA from ancient Egyptian mummies so he
sets out to replicate the mummification
process and it doing that by putting
small pieces of liver that he bought in
the store into the oven in the lab
and he managed to to isolate DNA which
suggests that the dehydration we are the
mumification process might preserve
genetic material
he then gets access to some real mermaid
specimens and he managed to recover DNA
from from those and uh that and they are
nearly 2 000 years old and he also
managed to publish the results in nature
this work led to two major realizations
one is that it's possible to extract DNA
from very old samples but also that DNA
of that age is massively contaminated
with other sources of DNA
he later uh realizes that some of the
longer DNA sequence that was published
probably came from Human contamination
and not from the moment
so Pebble becomes really a proponent for
establishing methods and standards to
isolate authentic DNA and not
contaminants and he becomes an
exceptionally critical and careful
scientists
in 1987 he joins the team in us to work
on the Genome of extinct mammals this
results in sequencing parts of the
ruler mammoth in 1994.
1990 people returns back to Europe to
focus on Neanderthal mitochondrial DNA
and in 2006 he announces this is uh at
the same time next-gen sequencing
instrument is coming in place so he
announces the plan to reconstruct the
entire Genome of neon results
and in 2010 they successful successfully
published a draft of the Neanderthal
genome that most scientists thought
impossible at that time
and actually further in 2010 they
successfully
identified an unknown homonym based on
genetic data alone
from DNA extracted from a small finger
bone found in the denisova cave in
Siberia
so they call this the new hominin
denisovance and High coverage genome was
published in 2012.
now let's look at the workflow from bone
to sequence
extracting DNA from ancient samples is
an extremely complex and challenging
process over time very old DNA degrades
becomes chemically modified and is
polluted with a large excess of DNA from
microorganisms that colonized the tissue
after the death of the body
uh in fact ancient samples can contain
hundred thousand to one million times
less endogenous DNA than fresh samples
with a consequence that even a tiny
contamination of human DNA on the
despotic for instance in the lab can
overwhelm the experiment completely
so table becomes a Pioneer in developing
standards and methods to isolate ancient
DNA away from contamination
and dynabeats he's used dynabits from
the very start and they played an
important role in separating out ancient
um both mitochondrial DNA or genomic DNA
from background
the first step of the workflow involves
grinding on the small or a small piece
of the bone
then DNA is extracted the pieces
converted to a DNA library in order for
the DNA to be to be sequenced
and the library step is typically where
dynabits are used
in one variant shown here at the at the
bottom uh they used it's called a single
stranded Library prep uh and this is
because when you do a double-stranded
library prep you trim of the ends so you
you may end up very small fragments
because these samples are so degraded so
in order to get more of the longer
sequences uh you you basically make also
a library from from Sing from each
strand
and this is where uh dynab is strapped
evidence comes handy in place
uh to fish out
through several steps you can basically
make libraries on each of the strands
you can actually also separate after
amplification do a size selection to
only continue with the longest fragments
and this actually
this technique has improved the
sequencing
uh tenfold
so now more what does this
understanding of ancient DNA mean for
the understanding of us as humans and
and human physiology
uh many of you have probably done a
Heritage An ancestry test to find a
verify ancestral relationships
some of these tests can also tell how
many neanderthal genes you have and how
you different percentage Neanderthal
compared to others
so why do most of us have Neanderthal
genes in our genome
so studying genomes
um we believe that neanderthals the
Nissans and today's humans actually us
the modern humans have some origin in
Africa and this goes quite far back we
talk about maybe millionaires
and that these ancestors then leave
Africa somewhere half a million years
ago
an investor new ratio they evolve into
neanderthals and in eastern Eurasia to
denisovans
and then over time
the two populations have moved and
overlapped at several times for example
in southern Siberia they have mixed and
had children together
then modern human
evolves in Africa so now we're talking
about like 50 to 70 000 years ago
and they start to spread out of Africa
to First mix with neanderthals and as
they move East to mix with denisolence
they're
sub genes from them are kept done in
non-africans so with the one to two
percent the undertal
um
contribution
and up to five percent or or so the
Nissan contribution in Oceania
uh and south of Sahara there are zero
percent now they're tall or denisovan
genes although probably also in Africa
the modern humans mixed with other forms
there
what was this uh genetic contribution of
Neanderthals or the the new Nissan genes
mean to us today and how does it
contribute to explain or Define us as
modern humans a couple examples
um have some physiological or medical
implications
one example involves the progesterone
receptor
where a genetic variant
exist outside Africa
this is the the v660l
and and it's almost certain that this
variant is coming from Neanderthals
the variant is associated with preterm
or premature birth which is a risk to
the child so this is actually suggesting
a selective disadvantage of of this
variant
however the opposite is true over time
the frequency of this variant has
instead increased and data from biobanks
are showing that the normal variant uh
the one that's not coming from the
undertale is associated with increased
miscarriages and families with less
siblings
so while in the undertal variant is
associated with pre-term birth is also
protective against miscarriages
resulting in more live births
so so this variant actually does
contribute to increased fertility
and it's interestingly Studies have
shown that if you give progesterone to
women as had previously experienced
miscarriages you can substantially
reduce the the
[Music]
later miscarriages
another example is related to the recent
covet pandemic a big study showed that a
very strong Factor on chromosome 3 there
are several genes there involved that
increase the risk of becoming very safe
the risk variant is coming from
neanderthals and exists in some humans
today a clinical picture in Sweden
showed that if you were not a carrier of
this variant and ended up in hospital we
had about seven percent risk of dying
whereas if you were a carrier you had
about a 13 risk of dying so almost a
doubling of your risk
when studying the frequency of this
Factor on chromosome 3 it is very
frequent in South Asia so India Sri
Lanka did almost 50 carriers while it's
completely absent in East Asia China and
Japan
so it looks like it has been selected
against in East Asia maybe they have
experienced the
Corona virus before and been selected
against
while it has some positive function in
South Asia and interestingly it shows
that this chromosome 3 region down
regulates ccr5 which is important for
HIV infection
and I can actually show that if you
carry this variant you have about 26
percent less chance of getting HIV
so basically then while the chromosome 3
Locus gives high risk of dying from
covid it is also associated with
decreased risk of HIV infection
third example is more defining us as
modern humans and can explain why we are
so different compared to earlier forms
for example the stone tools from
neanderthals were very similar
over the 400 000 years they existed
didn't really change much at all
and then suddenly when modern humans
came the technology changed rapidly
and art is another thing while
neanderthals had very primitive art
it's difficult to see what it depicts
modern human
you have much more figurative art
and another interesting thing is that
while Neanderthals
never crossed open water when they could
not see land on the other side modern
humans start to spread all over the
planets and they moved to Australia
Madagascar Americas
so
um
so why is this and one interesting
finding they have found is that
um
they have found actually three genes
involved in chromosomal segregation
that results in a slower metaphase this
is the phase where the chromosomes align
and they're going to be pulled apart
that is more that takes longer time and
seems to be more accurate
in in modern human variants compared to
Neanderthal variants
maybe then suggesting that
you modern humans have a better better
neural development and also a better
functional brain and you can also show
that within the undertale variants
you'll get more
[Music]
to say errors or fragments during this
this phase
so as you can see
studies of our closest relatives can
contribute to better understand who we
are as modern humans
and we will concluse about human
physiology
and as I mentioned dynabits and in
particular dynabits Thrift avidine has
played an important role together with
an estrogen sequencing in this work
I'm therefore happy to introduce to you
a new dynabeat that is specifically
optimized for Target enrichment in
extreme sequencing workflows
the first home some I want to share some
Basics about the dynabits technology
dynabits are truly monetized I mean
completely spherical
and mono dispersed meaning they appear
as single bits and they are invented in
Norway
they have become the gold standard of
magnetic beads especially in
immunodeagnostic applications and used
in about four or five billion tests or
several billion tests per year
they're also mentioned in more than 100
000 scientific Publications
so while there exists many different
vendors of magnetic particles
as you can yeah shown a few examples
here
only the uh not only have the quality of
the Dyna beats that you see in picture a
h
so
um what's important is really the
uniform size uh uniform magnetic
distribution make all the bits behave
the same in experiments
or the biggest Advantage is probably the
extremely high batch to batch
reproducibility and this is very
important secure same results Time After
Time year after year
good
so then our new Dynamite product it's
called Dynamite strepiving for Target
enrichment and is intended for
enrichment of Target DNA sequences made
during the library prep as part of
next-gen sequencing workflow
this is the one micron bead covalently
coupled with streptavidian
and again key benefits as I said
reproducibility and sensitivity
and you can learn more about
this product on our
webpage thermofisher.com
so then
um if you look at where this bits are
used in the Mexican sequencing workflow
so after fragmentation of the genome and
Library preparation
you can isolate a sub-fraction of the
genome by using specific probes that
hybridize to your targets of Interest
and since the probe is biotinolated it
will bind to the strep evidence on the
Beats it can recruit out of solution
you can view this in a direct way where
the biotin related probe is pre-coupled
to the dynabits and then hybridized to
the Target
or in an indirect way where the biotin
related probe is first hybridized to the
Target and then enriched using the the
beats
Target enrichment is ideal for instance
for exome sequencing or sequencing of a
panel of genes for instance oncogenes
wherein where instead of sequencing the
entire genome rather wants to achieve
higher coverage of a smaller fraction of
it
but still this method can also be used
in whole genome sequencing uh as you
know just shown in in this ancient
sequencing applications
to Simply Clean Up the sample
then I want to share some performance
data of these bits with you uh in the
fear to the left uh we compare these
these beats with other vendors and the
dynabits in red
uh and there and and the red dotted line
shows the threshold of the
concentrational libraries required
to to go to the to the next step to the
sequencing
and dynabits here produced the highest
concentration of final libraries
samples below the line will not qualify
and will not go further
then in the
in the figure to the to the right
um
then all the libraries that are
normalized to the same concentration for
sequencing and now the bars represent
the quality of sequenced or sequences
produced so the higher bar the higher
the bar is the higher the quality
um and again you see a really good
sequencing quality with the dynabits
uh in the last
bottom here
uh
this is shows how much sequence coverage
you can achieve
uh deeper coverage more it's to build a
consensus uh generally increases the
accuracy of results and especially for
clinical applications the coverage is an
important metric as deep coverage is
essential for rare variant air crawling
for instance
if you want to detect let's say a single
point mutation in in a cell that might
might be cancerous you want to to kind
of
distinguish that signal from noise so
the more coverage you have the the more
likely to detect the
that small difference
so I think
with that
um
I hope
you learn a little bit more about
this product as well as how these beads
are used in
for ancient DNA applications
and I can just my last slide I want to
thank you all for participating
here is just some
some thought or pictures from my local
from my own fossil collection
you see a fifth here a 50 million years
old
ish from I think this is from Green
River
[Music]
piranha like yeah fish
and also at the right
this is a 1.8 million years old Femur
from a southern Mammoth so this is
actually
lived way before
the wooly mammoth that uh
I think most
more
people are more familiar with better
existed also older ancestor versions of
mammoths
so with that thank you all and I'm ready
to move to
to live q a and to you Shelley
wonderful thank you Arlen for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar uh joining Ireland to help
answer your questions today we have
Camila Hannah and Ivana
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
um our first question today is do you
have any connection or collaboration
with peibo or his team
yeah I wish we we had actually uh since
his uh
is one of my favorite scientists
but at current at least not here in at
our site we don't have a have a
collaboration they they simply buy their
Beats from us
ah got it okay
um all right so the next question that
we have then is can you describe in more
detail the workflow on how the Dyna
beads are used in the ancient DNA field
yes sure uh actually they're used in
many different ways uh maybe one one uh
one thing is what I just uh showed uh
you know when you
in in this Library prep
um you have uh one of the
uh
adapters biotinylated and you can simply
done with the beads pull out the the
library fragments
uh or as I showed you with this single
stranded libraries you use
there are different tricks where you use
biotinolation and different oligos to to
basically form a double-stranded library
fragment and also use the dynabeat strap
evidence you can simply
because you get a mix of very small
fragments and longer fragments and if
you want to enrich for only the longest
one is the the dynabeads are are really
useful because you can simply heat the
nature of one strand
and and and your size selection on a GL
to continue and but also I mentioned the
mitochondrial
um
uh DNA work they did then they used
basically mitochondrial Gene secret
sequences as bait to pull out the
mitochondrial genes from a or ancient
mitochondrial genes from the background
of bacteria
so that's another application they have
used
very interesting thank you so much
um okay another question that we have is
is the product specific for targets uh
enrichments in the NGS workflow or can
it be used in more genetic ways
yeah so this product
is intended for uh kind of optimized or
attended for this
message and sequencing workflow but we
also have other
um
similar Syrup avidine products that more
generic use
okay the next question that we have is
the the person who asked the question
said I can see how dynaves has a clear
advantage over competing beads
um they're curious about cost comparison
and if there's a trade-off between cost
product availability accuracy and
efficiency those kinds of things
I don't know if Hannah you want to
cost is always a difficult question to
answer because it's so hard to say
regionally dependent but what we can say
with the accuracy is that we do both
high reproducibility in our products so
especially when you want a workflow to
move towards the NGS where it's crucial
to have robustness in your workflow to
have a successful result uh that that's
where you see the huge dynabeat
advantage
um you get the same answers or same
quality again and again
I think that's an important aspect in
one one way we can look at it is that we
invest a lot into the quality of the
data bits
but then in the
what you get back is more successful
than or successful experiments this goes
back to the batch to
bachelor-producibility
you can expect same results always also
we kind of build in this
this extra quality building will also
save costs with the customer not to
mention frustrations
yes absolutely okay wonderful thank you
um the next question that we have uh for
the team is how forensic science and
developmental biology are intertwined
because how are they intertwined is the
question
forensic science and developmental
biology
um
yeah that's uh
maybe I don't know if hamna or Camilla
want to give it a shot I'm not exactly
sure
we understand the question correctly
yeah not sure maybe
well we can what we can do is always
push that one through and maybe you have
your team take a look at it and all the
questions that come through what will be
will be sent to you but there is a yeah
but but there is a point I would say
that forensics
um uh studies I mean if they mean more
like the ancient DNA versus forensics
that's uh maybe that's what the question
is about that's very interesting because
then you also have Thai any tiny amounts
of DNA in the background of a lot of
contaminants and how to get that you
know fish out that with the quality I
think that's a very good question and
and I see that they are actually
intertwined in that in the sense that
you have to have be particularly careful
to enrich for the right material away
from the vast excess or background
[Music]
yeah
the type of challenging samples between
forensic and this type of thing yeah a
lot of overlap exactly in in the in the
challenge with the the samples from
forensics versus this ancient DNA
samples
good excellent okay
um another question that we have is is
dynamite do they help in to isolate the
the self-free DNA from liquid biopsy
indeed
um that is absolutely a perfect match
for this um Dynamite functionality
um it is a developed precisely for this
type of um how to say Precision medicine
workflow where you want to enrich for a
specific panel of ongo targets
moving into the NGS type readouts
well as we sort of wait for a couple
more questions to come in I just wanted
to see if your team had anything any
thoughts that you wanted to share uh in
the meantime
no well
um
I think
I think we kind of showed a little bit
uh nice thing about the dynabits and the
strep dividend beats is also the higher
versatility you know you basically as
long as they have something biotinolated
you can basically
use these beads for anything
still when we are saying that this the
new product is kind of intended and
optimized for the Nixon workflow you can
of course use it for other things but
it's more likely optimized everything
specifically for that workflow
wonderful wonderful it doesn't mean that
this speed does not work in all the
workflows
okay well
well Maryland for your time today
we'd like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Therma Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
so before we go I'd like to thank the
audience as well for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
rates will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's Live Events
so thank you so much again and until
next time
thank you bye-bye